А що сказати? Тільки через мій труп? Це дикість.
І потім, якщо всі так скажуть, всі мами, всі дружини, хто буде захищати Батьківщину?
27-річний Ілля Самойленко на війні вже сім років,
однак широкому загалу "азовець" став відомий в останні два місяці -
спочатку як захисник Маріуполя з бездоганною англійською.
Тепер до цього додався статус "рупора" військових з заблокованого військами РФ заводу "Азовсталь".
Попри те, що кілька років тому Ілля мав серйозне поранення -
втратив одне око і кисть руки, після лікування він повернувся на війну.
Його мама, Алла Самойленко, вважає, що він не міг без свого полку і побратимів.
Я ніколи не керувала його життям. Серйозно.
Це може звучати дивно, але навіть маленьким, він, прокидаючися до школи, я у нього питала "Це чи це?"
І він обирав. І тут так само. Я йому казала: може, ти вже повернешся?
А потім, якийсь час тут, коли він відходив від поранення, я бачила,
що він мається, що йому важко, що він хоче до хлопців.
У бомбосховищах заблокованого заводу "Азовсталь" у Маріуполі зараз перебувають сотні українських військових.
На єдиний госпіталь на території заводу російські війська скинули кілька бомб.
Тепер численні тяжко поранені військові не можуть отримати жодної медичної допомоги,
навіть бинтів, дезінфекторів і чистих перев'язок.
Ельвірин чоловік - морський піхотинець, також замкнений на заводі.
Жінка понад місяць не має з ним зв'язку.
Іноді вона отримує повідомлення від його побратимів, просто про те, що чоловік живий.
Хлопці наразі там гниють заживо. Як би це страшно не звучало.
Це навіть абсурдно звучить, що в 21 сторіччі люди гниють.
Про яку стерильність можна взагалі говорити в підвалі?
Син Євгена Сухарнікова вступив до "Азова", коли йому виповнився 21 рік.
Тепер військовому - 24, він з побратимами також перебуває на "Азовсталі".
Євген каже, що з початку повномасштабної війни Росії проти України
для його сина було принципово стати пліч-о-пліч з бойовими товаришами в Маріуполі.
Він був один з найкращих у підрозділі, і його направили на сержантські курси.
І вони знаходилися взагалі на Західній Україні. Дуже далеко.
І ось в той день, зранку, 24-го лютого він був дуже далеко від Маріуполя.
І потім він почав пробиватися до своїх. Повертатися спеціально!
Чоловік у розпачі, оскільки наразі гарантовано успішної схеми для порятунку бійців з "Азовсталі" немає.
Однак близькі захисників активно працюють над впровадженням екстракції -
процедури, за якої військових вивозять на територію третьої, дружньої країни.
Тоді врятовані воїни беруть на себе зобов'язання не долучатися до бойових дій, допоки війна не закінчиться.
З точки зору військової науки, це те саме, що їх вб’ють.
Вони не будуть приймати участь. Але це просто такий людський крок - ну, не вбивайте їх.
Вони там вже будуть і ніяк не зашкодять ворогу.
На думку Євгена, найкращий кандидат для екстракції і з політичної, і з географічної точок зору - Туреччина.
Адже Маріуполь рохміщений на березі моря, а Туреччина має відносно дружні стосунки з РФ.
Рідні бійців вже почали налагоджувати зв'язки з турецькою стороною.
І ми звертаємося саме до пана Ердогана, президента Туреччини, зробити такий крок гуманітарний.
Стати миротворцем, героєм. Відрядити цивільне судно,
щоб забрати наших людей і перевезти на територію Туреччини. Таким чином врятувати їх.
Однак така складна процедура не відбудеться лише за клопотанням родичів, необхідне втручання влади.
Хлопець Лізи - також "азовець". Дівчина нарікає, що поки не бачить ефективних переговорів щодо екстракції.
Особливих ілюзій щодо їхнього порятунку нібито не мають і самі "азовці" у пастці заводу.
Може, вони щось роблять, бо в новинах Зеленський каже, що вони дуже хочуть,
що вони дипломатичним шляхом хочуть це зробити.
Провести цю екстракшн, але зараз ефекту нуль.
Бо коли я пишу своєму хлопцю, щоб тримались, він каже:
"Не кажи нам так, бо нам вже два місяці кажуть і нічого не роблять."
Вони взагалі кажуть, що влада їх просто кинула, що їй класно,
що хлопці в заводі стримуюсь величезну кількість військових.
Алла Самойленко натомість вірить, що механізм порятунку чоловіків і жінок з "Азовсталі" існує.
Однак, на думку матері, йому сприятимуть приховані процеси на дипломатичних, політичних рівнях,
а не відкриті для широкого загалу процедури.
Це має бути хитрий, може, прихований механізм, від гравців, які мають вплив.
Бо я боюся, що Україна - це не той гравець, який може мати великий вплив на Путіна.
У нас немає того ресурсу, з яким ми можемо з ними спілкуватися.
Тож родини бійців усіма силами намагаються принаймні привернути увагу світової спільноти до "Азовсталі".
Зокрема, дружини військових відвідали Папу Римського з проханням посприяти порятунку чоловіків і жінок з заводу.
Також родичі ініціювали петицію, в якій закликають ООН і регіональних лідерів усього світу
невідкладно почати процедуру екстракції.
За тиждень петиція набрала понад 1 мільйон 300 тисяч підписів.
Євген Сухарніков вважає, що один з несприятливих факторів для рятувальної операції полягає в тому,
що довкола полку "Азов" роками формувався викривлений імідж щодо їхніх праворадикальних поглядів.
Батька бійця це обурює.
Всі ці кошмарні речі, які кажуть про "Азов", про їхній нацизм, гіпернаціоналізм, це просто абсолютні дурниці.
Ну, покажіть мені якийсь нацистський загін, в якому нормально служать чи мусульмани, чи євреї, чи люди,
які взагалі української мови не знають, чи кримські татари, які там з ними пліч-о-пліч.
Нерідко родичі дізнаються про ситуацію на "Азовсталі" з новин. Це особливо боляче.
Командир морської піхоти Сергій Волина порівняв те, що нині відбувається з ним і його побратимами,
з пекельним реаліті-шоу: "Ми - військові, боремося за життя, використовуємо кожен шанс для порятунку,
а весь світ просто спостерігає цікавий сюжет!"
Навколо них шоу. І вони в онлайні, це дуже страшно, жити у відчутті, що ось зараз тобі транслювала дитина твоя,
що він спокійний, що все буде добре.
А потім проходить пів дня, ти читаєш якусь жахливу новину, про те, що туди пустили хімічну речовину,
чи що якийсь черговий чорт з російських військ загрожує їм ядерною зброєю чи чимось ще таким... Ну, це жахливо…
Коли я кожного ранку прокидаюся, мені хочеться себе вщипнути.
Переконатися, що я не сплю. Тому що те, що таке може бути з твоєю дитиною - це не можна уявити.
Це реально наче не по-справжньому все.
Попри відчай, з яким щоденно борються рідні військових з "Азовсталі", вони розуміють, що здаватися не мають права.
Найважливіше, що ми маємо зробити - їх врятувати.
Ніяка проблема не може порівнятися з тим, що переживають вони.
Кожна година - це одне життя.
Ми не маємо навіть морального права падати духом, зневірюватись або відмовлятись від будь-яких дій.
У мене є хороший стимул. Я хочу врятувати сина.
Дуже часто мені хочеться просто впасти на землю і плакати.
Але намагаюся якось в собі сили знаходити.
Мене дуже сильно тримає думка, що якщо я буду у відчаї, це буде дуже сильно шкодити моїй дитині.
Я намагаюся побачити його майбутнє. Яким воно буде. Світле.
Я його візуалізую таким, яким я хочу його бачити - успішним і щасливим.